là où s'il ya beaucoup de choses sauf
que il est normal qu'on se rend on
appelle ça l'état devant la puissance
publique puisque ça a été inventé pour
ça pour protéger le groupe et quel est
l'état le monopole de la violence
légitime comme comme la très nette dit
max weber
ensuite le problème c'est que quand on
voit ce que vous dites y'a eu de
l'autorité mais pas toujours il ya aussi
de l'autoritarisme et parfois un manque
d'autorité sur moi j'ai vécu des
situations dans certains secteurs
géographiques ou le confinement ne
s'appliquait pas à tout le monde et où
l'état était faible avec les forts et
fort avec les faibles et ce qui est à
travers très français
réellement ou comme on n'a pas su faire
de deux micros isolement de personnes
contaminées on a fait des macros mesure
très pénalisante pour le groupe mais
parce qu'en france on isole pas les
malades voilà le whisky et c'est ce qui
était pour enfin mois jugé là-dessus
j'ai
proposé casser des oeufs pour faire une
omelette et jeudi il fallait mieux
isoler de façon un peu plus vie
rigoureuse les malades mais laisser plus
de liberté pour le groupe je me suis
opposé intellectuellement mais après sa
fameuse phrase d'alain résistance et
obéissants sur la ligne verte une
citoyens orist intellectuellement ans
résiste intellectuellement mais en
habitant que c'est légitime mais on a eu
des moments où on s'est posé la question
moi je me suis posé la question aux
cantons pas dans l'illégitime complet et
ça se joue à quelques semaines peut-être
un quelques jours et mais là dessus
l'oeil avait des quartiers où il n'y
avait pas de confinement le soir où il
ya des bandes entières dehors quoi et
l'état ne regardez pas ils voyaient même
d un strauss était
lé premier couvre-feu après confinement
ça va être l'été 2020 on disait ne
regardez pas trop quoi et nous envoyer
la police municipale mais ça te dérange
et je voyais bien que ça dérange et
l'état mais aussi hambourg you s'étaient
confinement était admirable de gens
survivent dans des toutes petites sur
femme aimait les mots c'est pour ça que
moi aujourd'hui il faut ouvrir les
espaces publics mais messi la règle
s'applique elle doit s'appliquer parce
que parce que 30 vous créez de la
justice c'est un rapport de force est
malheureusement très souvent c'est ce
qui arrive en france donc il y avait
parfois un peu d' autoritarisme
communicationnel ont montré qu'on allait
contrôler la qui ont fait venir la
caravane médiatique puis à côté de ça on
voyait des situations qui était anormal
[Musique]